good morning believe nation today's
message is no your mission over to you
Steve Irwin awake this recipe me go if
there's one thing that I Steve Irwin
would want to be remembered for its be
remembered for passion and enthusiasm
conservation is my job my life my whole
persona my mission is to help
entrepreneurs I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs it's my mission I can't
help it it makes me come alive it just
gives me energy to be around
entrepreneurs and to help them out and
I'm not the most social person that may
not come across I watching videos
because you see the the most outgoing
version of me you see me yelling and get
an excited and energized to come with
ideas and that's definitely part of who
I am but I'm really an introvert you
know I need my quiet time I need my
alone time I hate networking events I
hate dinner events and a lot of social
events I try to avoid them as much as
possible I just feel awkward and it's
not something that I enjoy doing and if
I'm meeting somebody you know if I mean
in some way to the social event I don't
know how to make small talk I'm not a
big fan of it but if I find out that you
are an entrepreneur the game has changed
I am a different person for whatever
reason I'm asking a million questions I
want to know all about your business I
want to see if there's a way that I can
help you I want to give I want to see
you be hugely successful I want to see
you reach your goals and your dreams
it's like a switch turns on and I can't
help myself I got to give you insane
value even though there's no there's
nothing coming back great like I'm not
asking for any money I'm asked to be a
part of your business nothing I just
want to give I love helping
entrepreneurs and I want to see you be
massively successful I can't help but I
don't know what it is about me it's some
strange thing that just makes me come
alive and my mission is to help a
billion entrepreneurs it motivates me it
fuels me and makes me come alive and I
hope you have a mission that does that
for you so the question the day today is
what's your mission that gets you
excited leave it in the comments below
I'm going to join a discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press 0